c'est un événement elle est en direct
avec nous lors qu'est ce qu'on en pense
ce vendredi eva longoria l'autre a dit
[Applaudissements]
et
wae
wahaha
[Applaudissements]
j'aime dire que je vais passer deux
jours avec
eva merci d'être là non merci ça m'a
fait réfléchir ah bah moi aussi je suis
tellement heureux de vous revoir on
s'était vus a longtemps mais beaucoup dé
temps mais moi je n'ai jamais oublié
mais j'ai deux en deux ans de
fait on sent qu'il n'est pas venu on
aurait là ouais ouais je sais moi aussi
ça fait dix ans que je parvenu aux états
unis
j'ai besoin de prendre un peu de recul
mais je suis très très heureux de vous
voir ce soir eva est on plus demain il
ya le gala pour la fondation global gift
foundation et je voudrais dire eva elle
se donne à fond pour cette fondation je
vous dis c'est un truc de fou elle ne
lâche rien c'est une de ses priorités et
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup aussi
parce que lé pas fake un tout ce qu'elle
fait elle le fait à fond et je sais que
c'est très très important pour elle
c'est voilà c'est une des priorités de
sa vie elle veut dire bravo pour ça déjà
ça s'appelle le jean baptiste gala c'est
demain soir j'aurai l'honneur de le
présenter plus on va dîner pas répondu à
la même table
et son frère
était
alors déjà on va parler de l'objectif de
cette fondation ce que c'est très
important dites moi quel est l'objectif
et après où on va vous dire comment
donner aussi et comment aider cette
femme dissiper alors dites nous quelle
est cette fondation pour nos
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent ce
soit
nous le vent de fonds pour les femmes
pour des femmes différents pays et
chaque pays a ses propres besoins des
très dur en france en europe en crise y
est là des réfugiés au mexique nous
travaillons sur les tremblements de
terre il ya eu entre un commentaire
particulièrement important
qu il ya eu
finalement les besoins varient en
fonction des pays où nous sommes
présents et nous essayons d'aider les
femmes et les filles parce que la
promesse d'une femme en est sa famille
et c'est là où il est nous essayons
d'identifier des fondations sur place il
fait des choses extraordinaires où les
soutenons dans leur donne une plateforme
une voix familière véritablement grâce à
moi grâce à d'autres également et nous
leur remettons tout cela de ces femmes à
ses enfants ses réseaux câble exactement
faut savoir qu'à plusieurs galas 1 voilà
donc et va en fait exactement ya neuf
gars là en tout cas la
voilà donc qui va l sénégal à
une fois de temps en temps je vais dire
un mot français en partie à savoir ça
tombait à manger une fois que ton dans
le gazon anglais
leur maison
tous les très basses eaux
eh ben
eva je suis pas venu pour ça d'habitude
je fais chabat d'astortia
je te le dis je suis pas venu pour ça
mais il ya vraiment un amour chez moi
toi tu es franchement tu sais que pour
moi tu es la plus belle femme du monde
et je lis vraiment c
est pas pourquoi c'est aussi important
pour toi de dédé comme ça les gens et
pourquoi tu t'investis autour de cette
fondation
à goa pas de vous savez on a bondi dans
une à la famille philanthrope j'ai une
grande soeur
est atteinte d'un handicap belge et je
suis né dans ce numéro très fine encore
ma soeur légalement et donc le terme
bénévoles nous l'avons connu très clair
nous avons toujours essayé de joindre
aux autres et à la société et vous savez
à 24 ans connue je me rappelle très bien
que ma mère me disait un jour tu auras
une voix à faire entendre donc j'espère
que tu auras quelque chose à dire donc
finalement c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours porté en moi et je savais qu'un
jour j'accomplirai le travail que
j'accomplis aujourd'hui que je sois
connu ou pas dont six fois le travail
d'une vie pas le fait d'être actrice ou
d'être réalisatrice mais ce travail ans
après c'est pourquoi on se rappellera
marester aussi bon va sera rien vous
pour votre tout ce que vous avez fait
aussi un voilà mais c'est vrai que ça
restera aussi étrange maria c'est une
fierté d'avoir évacué qui est toujours
là qui est franchement qui perd présente
l'agencé qui est dans chaque pays où
elle va
ah ouais c'était 22 ans twenty two years
personnel ça c'est votre désarroi le
clac
à l'époque vous êtes toujours du tour
dont 19 cas et eva je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous êtes magnifique où
s'est pas vu depuis yonne non mais c'est
vrai on se connaît depuis très très
longtemps et c'est fou parce que non
mais vraiment l emb et c'est là que je
je vois en fait d'après produit chez là
que je vois que je me suis trompé depuis
toutes ces années
on a parlé sur mes critères de beauté
c'est vrai c'est un truc de fou quand
eva longoria arrive c'est vrai que ça
c'est c'était dingue tout moche ouais
non mais c'est vrai non mais vraiment
on dirait que vous avez toujours un
projecteur sur vous tellement vous êtes
illuminé tellement vous êtes plus
mineuse
et je n'en avais pas du tout les temps
des mariés l avoir à les marier c'est
une amie hortefeux
nous sommes dans la fredzone
done for gets the friend quoi
nous soit vous pouvez sortir
et va même ajouté